this game has flashing lights loud
noises and a few other things that may
possibly harm your eyes and ears
use windowed mode for best experience
all right
i will hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to
dot e y x
or sonic rommer
what is that is that a sonic
is that a big eyeball sonic
i would look at the camera but i i feel
like i need to keep my eyes on this
thing
hi
it's been a while since a sonic
exe type game been a while since any
type of
exe game
[Music]
oh
quit right now before it's too late
well
are you
usually i'm not too perturbed
and i'm willing to dive deep in but
something in my gut tells me i probably
should quit immediately my time's
running out oh
fascinating
well i mean i can't really run anywhere
can i
hmm
oh
whee
[Music]
okay i don't like the pulsating thing in
the foreground but
oh
well this seems to actually be working
quite well
okay
oh
no
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh oh oh
okay
do i go back
what do i do
ah
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
ah
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
well so far not too terrible
oh
hi
oh
hello
oh
hi
hey
that's just mean
what are you doing what are you guys
doing come on
[Music]
more than a little confused
sonic
oh
sonic
sonic
sauce
sonic
oh um
yeah me you had the beginning okay no
whoa no need to tell me twice
i'm on the way big guy um oh my eyes
seem to be doing a little funny thing
um
ah
[Music]
hi
hi knuckles
how you doing
you having a good time this is a fun
oh well that's a little
it's more than a little rude um
i thought that maybe we could
why
why do you why why why do i make you
what makes you enjoy all this so bad
we did nothing to you i don't know what
you're referring to
maybe tails was just right
about i
you love to see us suffer in every way
possible i'm not me it's you guys really
we don't deserve to go through this hell
hole
um
oh hi we do not oh okay
instead i do
[Music]
you are the one who deserves all the
pain i am not a masochist no matter what
people have said about me he's coming
now
what do you mean by that
oh
uh
all right
do you need like administrative
privileges or something
because
i mean that's negotia i could give that
to you if you wanted it
if if you wanted it
let's try something different
okay
oh
okay
wow this is lovely
the gang's all here hello
why rey
who who's rey why is there an eyeball in
the background
ray look out something's looking at you
rey
ray be careful
oh my god
well
oh god oh my god
somebody help me ah ray ray ray
ray
ray
oh ray
okay
well it's a good thing that you had two
lives ray so um
probably gonna be okay oh my god hi
how are you doing so you sonic or is
that knuckles maybe ray
i'll be watching you from now on it'll
be watching you from now on it it what
is it
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
this is gorgeous do i
am i
this me
oh
okay
we
i mean it seems pretty cool so far
everything seems very normal here
lovely
lovely
[Music]
whoa
awesome
is this actually like from one of the
games i i never know because i never
actually played any of the sonic games
[Music]
so fun and so free
oh god
oh god
i
felt like i was supposed to do something
a little better there but whatever
hi
what what are you
okay that seems unfair
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey um uh
i was running there you know it's not
really a big deal if it is watching oh
well i was going to say that like i'm
used to many people wow
watching me um
oh
[Music]
i thought that was the mythical it that
i've heard so much about
it might have been i i mean i'm i'm not
really one to say whether it was or was
not
um
anyway
i'm gonna go
[Music]
oh
my i'm trying to ride is that
oh my god
[Music]
okay oh that
[Music]
oh
did we make it
i'm creating such a beautiful family
right markiplier but still there nothing
compared to you
oh
wow
[Music]
hi
[Music]
oh
boy
oh
access to webcam declined ah it's
because i'm using it right now to record
[Music]
look i mean literally i'm i'm using it
to record i could i could turn it off i
guess if you want to really use it i
like try
maybe it'll work now
oh uh oh
i'm back hello what happened it's full
screen why
[Music]
the whimsy
the guys the whimsy
what magical whimsy
it's so whimsical
oh hi are you looking at me i can't tell
you don't ex you don't exactly have eyes
at the moment
hi
how are you
okay
i mean i'm fine with the staring contest
i once kicked ethan's
ass at a staring contest
okay
did that scare you then
whoa
yeah i think so
anyway back to the whimsy
it's beautiful
it's just goddamn gorgeous
what is i just hey okay
i did it
all right this really is beautiful
[Music]
oh i was trying to go a lot faster than
that at that moment
what do your sonic eyes ic
[Applause]
ah
that's a number
um i i feel like somehow you're gonna
try to pin this on me and make me take
the blame for this but i i really want
to say that uh all i did was um try to
have a fun time with sonic i may not
have seen the sequel to the sonic movie
however i feel like that's that's not
pertinent into the current situation of
where
we are at this juncture
oh
huh
tails
you have your eyes back
let's uh go on
yeah let's go on an adventure oh you're
not
you're not up to spinning
that's okay you're not up to jumping
either okay well
feeling a bit of a lazy day i get it
i've had those before certainly
kind of dark in this cave
oh
oh
hey
who are you
goodbye
oh
[Music]
what in the hell is behind you tails
well i mean don't look behind you for
sure definitely don't look behind you
that would be a terrible idea to look
behind you at the moment
i don't mean to concern you because you
look perfectly comfortable with the moan
i hate see you worried but you don't
have any rings at the moment and uh if i
know my sonic games properly is that
when you don't have rings uh you are in
danger
i don't see
any other reason around here why you
should feel in danger but just to be
safe why don't you get a ring
fails
sonic
um oh uh um sally
sammy sia sal
sao pal
huh
coming soon to me
oh
[Music]
ah
i
clear no why would i do that
why would i clear the data
why would i clear the data
clearing the data hey there's a thank
you
this is the end of version one we hope
you enjoyed a fragment of what's to come
in the future we would love to hear your
feedback as it would help us a lot to
improve and feel motivated for the
development of a complete version
wow
what happens if i open it again i want
to keep playing oh
i see
well um it has been a long long long
time since i played a sonic exe or any
type of exe games and it's fun to see
how they've evolved over time uh what's
fascinating is i could totally see this
as being anything horror related that's
not pertaining to sonic you could make
your own thing in this style and have it
be your own and if you made it just like
that it would be just as scary and
honestly a really fantastic horror game
so i can't wait to see what you make
next i'm sure that i'm totally fine and
there's nothing appearing behind me
slowly trying to consume my soul because
there's no way that i've unleashed an
infection upon myself and uh the
internet as a whole and you by watching
this video surely aren't also being
subjected to the horrors and the
nightmares that are coming to consume
you that have already consumed
everything that you know and love and i
am already long gone
because it's a pre-recording message
and if there was something happening to
me it would have already happened by now
all you're seeing is improvement of who
i once was
basically a fleshpoint a digital fresh
puppet
use your manipulator to get those of you
who trust me to click on this video
nearby
inviting me
[Music]
[Music]
you